Olá boa noite a todos por favor me deem
o feedback do áudio Se vocês me escutam
bem boa noite Carlos k Eliane beluco
Marta perz TAM
miquinha é um prazer est aqui com vocês
então já vou começar a minha
exposição me digam se o áudio tá legal
legal Eliseu obrigado boa noite Eliseu
nós vamos discutir aqui dois três
artigos e depois nós
vamos entrar nas perguntas muito bem
Imaginem vocês se fosse possível reduzir
os riscos de transtorno do espectro
autista e déf de atenção nas crianças
antes mesmo delas nascerem bem essa
possibilidade pode estar mais próxima do
que nós
imaginamos Então vamos desvendar estudo
fascinante que relaciona os níveis de
vitamina D de dado na mãe durante a
gravidez com a incidência de autismo e
hiperatividade em crianças então
acreditávamos que a suplementação de
vitamina D sim poderia reduzir essas
taxas de hiperatividade de autismo mas
aí está uma descoberta aparentemente
contraditória a suplementação tardia Ou
seja no segundo terceiro trimestre da
gestação parece não ter o mesmo efeito
Se você começar essa suplementação no
começo da
gestação Então vamos mergulhar nesse
estudo e entender os
detalhes então a vitamina D que na
verdade é um hormônio é frequentemente
associado só à saúde óssea mas vocês que
acompanham o canal sabem que ela é muito
mais do que isso o seu papel Se estende
muito além influenciando até mesmo a
parte psicológica
tem depressão associado a déficit de
vitamina D em adultos também a parte
sexual tá relacionada a isso mas em
relação às crianças a vitamina D tem a
ver influencia o desenvolvimento
neurológico então pesquisas anteriores
apontaram um possível
correlação entre níveis adequados de
vitamina D in gestantes e Menor risco de
transtorno de espectro autista ouf são
hiperatividade então estudos
observacionais
anteriores sugeriram uma associação
significativa entre níveis elevados de
vitamina D de dado da mãe materna na
gestação e uma redução dos diagnóstico
desses transtornos destacando a
relevância desse nutriente durante a
gestação então no estudo em questão que
foi conduzido com rigoroso modelo de
ensaio controlado randomizado foram
acompanhados 591 pares de mães e filhos
na Dinamarca para examinar os efeitos da
suplementação com vitamina D de dado
Então as dosagens
eram entre 2.800 unidades por dia e 400
unidades por dia então dentro da
Medicina integrativa funcional uma dose
até baixa então entre 400 e 2800
unidades por dia então eles estavam
começando a suplementação desde a 24ª
semana de gravidez até uma semana após o
parto Então os níveis de vitamina D
foram monitorados rigorosamente e os
diagnósticos de hiperatividade e de
autismo foram feitos por profissionais
treinados utilizando instrumentos
validados aos 10 anos de idade das
Crianças então um estudo longo né pegou
gestante deu vitamina D e viu 10 anos
depois o que aconteceu com as crianças
Então quais foram os resultados e
implicações desse estudo então
contrariando as expectativas a
suplementação de alta dose de vitamina D
alta dose para eles é 2800 por dia né
não se traduziu em uma redução
estatisticamente
significativa nas taxas de autismo ou de
hiperatividade porém veja bem aqu eles
estão correlacionando as doses que foram
dadas com as taxas de autismo e de
hiperatividade não quer dizer que eles
estão correlacionando com os níveis de
vitamina D no sangue das Mães Então isso
é muito importante porque você pode dar
1 unidades para uma mulher e ela tem um
efeito de aumento de vitamina D no
sangue completamente diferente do uma
que você tá dando 5000 Às vezes a pessoa
que tem problema genético não tem um
receptor bom de vitamina D tem a mutação
do receptor da vitamina D você tem que
dar uma dose muito mais alta de vitamina
D para ela ter o mesmo efeito no sangue
do que uma pessoa que não tem a mutação
então foi por isso no meu entendimento
que não houve essa correlação
estatística porém no entanto foi
observado que mulheres com níveis mais
altos de vitamina D Ou seja no sangue tá
não é o tanto de dose que tá dando mas o
nível de vitamina D no sangue Então
essas mulheres que tinham níveis mais
altos de vitamina D no sangue tiveram
crianças com menor habilidade de serem
diagnosticados com as duas doenças Então
essa
Associação destacou-se
com níveis de vitamina D materna entre
55 e
110 nanomoles por litro Então
curiosamente os níveis de vitamina D das
crianças não das Mães né tô falando das
crianças agora não mostraram uma
associação Clara com os riscos de
desenvolver duas doenças né autismo e
hiperatividade então enfatizando que o
foco pode estar nos níveis maternos
durante a gestação Tá
então vamos fazer algumas considerações
e tecer aqui alguns comentários sobre
limitações desse estudo então a
administração de vitamina D somente após
a 24ª semana pode ter impactado os
resultados Ok eu teria começado isso
antes visto que a formação dos sistemas
neurais ocorre majoritariamente no
primeiro trimestre da gestação Além
disso fatores estilo de vida não
controlados no estudo como a prática
regular de exercícios ao ar livre pode
ter influenciado os níveis de vitamina D
de maneira independente da suplementação
Então esse fator destaca que existe uma
complexidade em isolar a influência de
uma única variável e há necessidade de
considerar um espectro Mais amplo de
comportamentos e condições ambientais
obviamente né pessoal durante a
gestação Então quais seriam os próximos
passos e vamos fazer aqui um apanhado
Geral do quadro maior Então apesar do
estudo não ter encontrado um efeito
Claro da
suplementação mas sim da correlação
entre a vitamina D no sangue e essas
duas doenças vitamina D no sangue da
gestante certo deixar bem claro isso a
presença de uma associação consistente
então entre níveis mais elevados de
vitamina D na mãe e o menor risco de
Diagnóstico Clínico de autismo e TDH
sustenta que essa é uma área promissora
para futuras investigações então estudos
futuros deverão considerar intervenções
mais precoces mais cedo na gestação além
de ser feitos ajustes para variáveis
genéticas como eu tô explicando a gente
tem mutação do Gene do receptor da
vitamina D
e também fazendo ajuste para estilo de
vida para quem toma mais sol quem toma
menos sol e outros hábitos então
oferecendo assim um quadro mais completo
sobre a relevância da vitamina D no
neurodesenvolvimento
fetal
né Bem pessoal esse é o primeiro estudo
então Eh se vocês conhecem alguém
grávida importante ela tomar ômega3 e
e vitamina D com K2 né fiquem atentos a
isso vocês TM alguém na família que está
gestante
Ok boa noite Adriana Boa noite Pedro
Luiz benette e boa noite miram vamos ao
segundo artigo do
dia
bem esse próximo artigo que nós vamos
discutir é uma análise sobre se o
exercício aeróbico o exercício de força
ou resistência ou a combinação dos dois
se podem
ter Impacto significativo na melhora da
Saúde cardiovascular Então qual desses
sistemas qual desses dessas combinações
é melhor só
aeróbico só força ou a combinação de
força para melhorar a saúde
cardiovascular Então vamos analisar isso
hoje então vamos falar de um
estudo que durou um ano teve um ano de
duração ele se concentrou no impacto da
atividade física nos fatores de risco de
doenças cardiovasculares então foram
ados 406 participantes todos foram
caracterizados como inativos fisicamente
sobrepeso ou
obesidade então esses gordinhos in
nativos foram divididos em quatro grupos
diferentes para prática regular de
exercício surpreendentemente os
resultados mostram um notável impacto na
diminuição dos riscos
cardiovasculares em grupos que
realizaram tanto exercício aeróbico Ok
isoladamente E também o grupo que fez
uma combinação de exercícios aeróbicos e
de resistência mas naquele grupo que só
fez exo de resistência não foi observado
o ganho de saúde
cardiovascular Então vamos detalhar
porque isso supostamente acontece o que
nós precisamos considerar em nossa
rotina de exercício para maximizar os
benefícios paraa saúde do coração
certo então vamos compreender o estudo e
os
participantes Então antes de mergulhar
nos detalhes é essencial entender quem
foram os participantes e como o
experimento foi conduzido estruturado
Então esse conhecimento nos ajudará a
interpretar as descobertas e aplicar de
maneira prática Então os
406 participantes Idade Média 50 anos
uma distribuição quase igual entre
homens e mulheres Eles foram Rigor ente
selecionados eles compartilhavam
características comuns uma vida
sedentária pressão alta sobrepeso ou
obesidade Então esse perfil é importante
é relevante porque obviamente aumenta o
risco para essas doenças que estão sendo
estudadas nesse
estudo e é uma coisa muito comum né essa
esse perfil muito comum então isso é
relevante né porque representa uma
parcela significativa da população
adulta luta hoje que luta com desafios
similares de saúde Então esse grupo foi
dividido de maneira aleatorizada né
randômica em quatro subgrupos exercício
aeróbico exercício de resistência que de
força combinação de aeróbico e
resistência e um grupo de controle que
não praticava nenhum exercício regular
então cada grupo de
exercícios comprometeu-se a três sessões
semanais de 60 minutos então três vezes
semana uma hora Cada sessão e foram
orientados pela para fazer a dieta lá
que é bem comum nos Estados Unidos que é
a dieta Dash que é a dieta específica
para hipertensão arterial e essa dieta
Dash ela tem um Enoque na redução do
consumo de sódio e a ingestão de
alimentos considerados saudáveis Ok
então vamos falar dos
resultados Então os participantes foram
engajados né Em cada um dos seus grupos
então começaram a se fazer as medições o
foco estava num pontuação que era
composta por risco de doença
cardiovascular que incluía pressão
arterial diastólica colesterol
LDL glicose em jejum e percentual de
gordura corporal Então os resultados
demonstraram uma clara vantagem dos
exercícios combinados
aeróbicos com resistência ou apenas
isoladamente os aeróbicos o grupo de
exercício aeróbico e o grupo combinado
viram melhorias significativas na
pontuação de risco de doe
cardiovascular então houve melhora em
geral né desses parâmetros
o colesterol HDL né o dito colesterol
bom aumentou nos grupos de exercício de
modo geral né então interessantemente o
grupo de resistência viu um aumento na
massa corporal
magra quer dizer não é é uma coisa que
não não seria esperada né houve então um
aumento de massa magra no grupo que fez
exercício de resistência certo que
obviamente é um benefício adicional para
composição corporal e paraa
força então além dos marcadores
tradicionais de saúde cardiovascular é
fundamental nós considerarmos os
indicadores não tradicionais como
aptidão cardiorespiratória a força
muscular né pois a capacidade de nosso
corpo oxigenar o sangue e a manutenção
da força tem grandes implicações paraa
saúde a longo prazo então o estudo
descobriu que a capacidade respiratória
que é traduzido pelo pico de vo2 e a
força muscular aumentaram
significativamente em todos os grupos de
exercício comparados ao controle e essa
melhora foi particularmente notável no
grupo de exercícios combinados então
considerando a forte correlação entre a
função cardiorespiratória e a
mortalidade por todas as causas e entre
a força muscular e a saúde a longo prazo
esses achados são importantes então por
exemplo um aumento de um met né que é
uma medida de aumento de consumo de
energia está associado a uma redução de
13 a 19% no risco de mortalidade por
todas as causas e doenças
cardiovasculares Então vamos
correlacionar esses resultados com a
prática né O que pode ser útil para nós
né como é que isso pode ser aplicado no
mundo real certo na meu entendimento é
uma prova que você tem que fazer as duas
coisas o aeróbico e o exercício de força
eu não faria só aeróbico por causa do
problema da sarcopenia da perda de massa
muscular que vai acontecendo a medida
que a gente vai envelhecendo e que
aumenta o risco de fraturas aumenta o
risco de também da pessoa ter morte
precoce Então os ganhos em saúde
cardiovascular sugerem que é claro vamos
combinar as formas de
exercício ao se combinar aeróbico e
exercício de força vamos beneficiar de
ambos a melhoria da aptidão
cardiorespiratória né pelos aeróbicos e
o aumento de força pelos exercícios de
resistência então isso não significa
necessariamente dedicar mais tempo a a
um exercício ou outro mas sim otimizar o
tempo né que nós temos então eu
particularmente
faço 15 minutos de
aeróbico e por volta de 50 minutos de
resistência tá Então temos que dividir
nosso tempo entre atividades aeróbicas e
resistência essa abordagem equilibrada
que é meio óbvio né pode oferecer uma
proteção mais abrangente contra doenças
cardiovasculares do que apenas focarem o
tipo de exercício né então como é que eu
sugiro para vocês caminhada rápida para
quem já tá bem acostumado uma
corridinha ciclismo né para o aeróbico
também natação para quem gosta seguido
treinamento com pesos ou exercício com
peso corporal calistenia né para quem
não quer usar peso então é importante
encontrar atividades que sejam
sustentáveis e prazerosas a longo prazo
para ter adesão
Ok então é importante que você aderindo
aos exercícios tem que lembrar que as
melhorias na sa de cardiovascular são
possíveis mesmo sem perda de peso tem
gente não vai perder peso mas vale a
pena mesmo assim tá atividade física
regular independentemente de mudança de
balança e às vezes a pessoa até ganha
peso mas porque ela ganhou músculo e
perdeu gordura e se ela não fizer uma be
impedância ela não vai nem saber disso
né então a atividade física vai
proporcionar benefícios substanciais
obviamente pro coração e pro corpo como
todo certo
pessoal vamos então a às perguntas
Adriana tá fazendo uma pergunta aqui
relacionada que eu tô
falando para quem está iniciando como
fazer sou muito
magra Adriana começa então com exercício
de força faz pouco aeróbico faz 10
minutos de aeróbico depois faz uns 50 de
musculação e começa a fazer
suplementação de proteína o Protein
proteína do câo proteína da carne
proteína da soja proteína da ervilha
proteína do Arroz proteína do colágeno
tem várias Fontes aí tá então faz
experimentação proteica faz força existe
força e no seu caso eu faria um
pouquinho menos de aeróbico Tá mas faz
10 minutos de aeróbico bicicleta
caminhada rápida como eu falei ou
natação ou ciclis
ciclismo é mais complicado você não vai
fazer ciclismo e depois fazer musculação
fica meio difícil né mais fácil você
fazer esteira ou elíptico na academia ou
a bicicleta na academia mesmo né a fixa
10 minutos e depois você vai pra
musculação Beleza então vamos
para as dúvidas do
documento
primeira pergunta
kécia criança do sexo masculino 15 anos
TSH alto de quase sete Anti TPO bem alto
queda de cabelo hormônio de tireoide T3
T4 reverso Total normais Será que tá
normal mesmo sei lá né melhor entrar com
Puran logo meio receio conseguir ainda
regularizar a situação com bons hábitos
e acabar entrando com medicação que será
para toda a vida bem
eh deve est já com hipotiroidismo
subclínico provavelmente T al mas ele tá
compensando com TSH al né Ele é jovem
ainda tem que esse rimoto aí tirar leite
tirar derivados do leite tirar o glúten
fazer exame de intolerância alimentar
depois tirar o glut tirar o
leite e entrar com ldn né louos nutrex
naut de baixa dosagem entrar com black
Comin né cominho Preto entrar com
selênio entrar com
iodo entrar com vitaminas no complexo
B talvez zinco né tem que ver como é que
tá o zinco
dele tem que fazer o tratamento né tem
que porar um médico que entende medicina
estilo de vida medicina funcional certo
eh não sei se você estão ao vivo queessa
Mas se estiver
podemos elaborar um pouco mais vamos pro
próximo
aqui Maria
[Música]
Helena muitas pessoas envolveram
intolerância a estamina depois do covid
sim é verdade
eh foi a 40 anos na gravidez tive
urticária que coçava tanto até sangrar
durante os 9 meses no pescoço dobra do
braço região atrás do joelho médicos
nunca souberam o que era só aplicava em
mim injeção de celestone soluspan hoje
eu sei que foi essa tal de inanç
histamínica tem Live sobre isso tem tem
Live sobre isso
sim mas tem material também no canal da
doutora
eh Fer Janete Fer tá eu vou digitar aqui
para
você o nome da Janete Fer ela tem lives
um canal menor do que o meu bem menor
mas tem ela tem um um enfoque nesse
nessa questão aí tá então
jeanete Fer tá ela procura esse nome no
no YouTube que você vai achar o canal
dela aí tem material sobre mas eu falei
também de de intolerância tamica no meu
canal Procura no meu no canal dela
tá Carlos ketman caros Doutor
considerando a qualidade antioxidante
seletiva da água molecularmente
hidrogenada pergunto se seu uso pode
tornar
interessante alterar reduzir dosagem
algum suplemento antioxidante como com
enzima q10 vitamina C e picnogenol binol
do ponto de vista da oxidação muito
difíc responder isso por uma razão
simples tá
eh como é que eu vou medir esse stress
oxidativo tem exame para isso tá existe
exame mas não são exames de rotina
são difíceis de conseguir poucos
Laboratórios e o plano não cobre se você
puder medir de maneira objetiva usando o
hidrogênio molecular como é que está o
seu estress oxidativo talvez você possa
abrir mão de todos esses suplementos aí
que você tá falando mas sem essa medida
objetiva fica difícil saber
e se deve ou não manter ou suspender o
bom funcionamento da catalase em
conjunto com o consumo da água
molecularmente
hidrogenada pare ser uma solução
perfeita bom funcionamento da catalase
eu não sei o que você quis dizer com
isso tá catalase sim é uma enzima que
nós temos que quebra O peróxido
hidrogênio Não não é a única enzima que
faz
isso mas como é que você vai saber se a
catalase tá funcionando bem eu não
conheço um exame direto para ver
catalase
tá não conheço esse exame existe para
ver produtos finais de
oxidação geralmente são produtos de
oxidação de gorduras e de
DNA que você vê no sangue mas isso é uma
maneira indireta de ver né você não tá
vendo diretamente o nível da enzima
antioxidante se existe esse exame eu não
conheço
certo não sei se eu respondi da maneira
que você queria
Mas se você tiver aí Car acho você tá né
podemos elaborar um pouco mais
[Música]
tá mais uma pergunta do Carlos
eh se a mesma neutraliza peróxido
nitrito Isso significa que poder Sera
ter uma pequena tolerância com alguns
embutidos como salame
defos sim logicamente você vai ter maior
tolerância a todo tipo
de oxidante usando água hidrogenada Tá
mas cuidado não vai exagerar só porque
você tá usando água
hidrogenada próxima
pergunta
miram Boa noite poderia explicar o que
causa uma gosma na garganta com um pouco
de pigarro que pode ser feito e
geralmente é o muco que tá grosso né Tá
espesso Por que que o muco tá grosso tá
espesso pode ser vários motivos mas
falta de água é um
falta de hidratação é um outro motivo é
que você
teve algum problema para eliminar isso
tá com movimento ciliar lá do trato
respiratório inferior funcionando
mal então pode ser um problema aí
de falta de NS cisteína né que é falta
de glutationa
e melhor maneira de de resolver isso é
tomando água bastante água e fazendo
inalação e usando nac nac 600
MG duas vezes ao
dia Maria Helena É verdade que a
espirulina aumenta a potência da cúrcuma
não sei não me lembro de ter visto um
estudo falando disso muito mais do que a
pimenta a pimenta não aumenta a potência
da cúrcuma ela só aumenta a absorção tá
não confunda absorção com potência
segundo o médico é 40 vezes mais porque
espirulina é um potente antioxidante Não
mas aí a absorção da cucumina não tem
nada a ver com oxidante ou antioxidante
tem a ver com tanto que entra no
organismo tá Isso foi dito no programa
do Fernando betet por um médico Dr
Alexandre Garcia tá o que eu faria o que
eu acho que faz mais sentido Hoje é você
usar uma curcumina de alta absorção tem
várias aí no
mercado e Hoje Eu Tô evitando de dar a
pimenta preta junto com a cúrcuma
primeiro porque tem gente que tem
problemas da irritação no
intestino segundo que a curcumina de Alo
absorção é mais garantido que vai
absorver tá essa história que spirulina
vai aumentar a absorção de cúrcuma Pode
até ser verdade mas eu não vi Tá
inclusive deixa eu fazer uma pesquisa
rápida
aqui para ver se tem alguma coisa aqui
tá
Então vamos lá eh
espirulina aumenta ou
[Música]
não colocar absorção certo absorção de
cúrcuma Vamos ver que a gente acha aqui
na no serviço que eu tenho aqui de
Inteligência Artificial que pega os
artigos
Ahã tá tem sim evidências de que a
espirulina pode aumentar a absorção e
biodisponibilidade da cúrcuma um estudo
mostrou que após 12 semanas de consumo
de um suplemento com baixa dose
espirulina e cúrcuma os níveis cé de
curcumina aumentaram vários resultados
mencionam os benefícios da combinação de
espirulina cúrcuma e gengibre in shor
suplementos que pode ter um efeito
sinérgico no entanto não não foram
apresentadas evidências diretas e
conclusivas de estudos específicos
avaliando se espirulina aumenta absorção
de cúrcuma
gozado ele tá falando isso aqui embaixo
né porque em cima ele falou que tinha um
estudo de 12 semanas seriam necessários
mais estudos clínicos comparando a BID
disponibilidade da CC isolada versus a
combinação com a as espirulina Para
comprovar esse efeito de forma
definitiva tem indícios tá de que pode
acontecer
isso deixa eu olhar uma outra
Inteligência Artificial
[Música]
aqui pronto achei aqui V deixa eu ver
aqui em outros artigos
aqui que que se fala a respeito disso
Ah tá esse aqui falou que tem sim um
impacto notável da espirulina na
biodisponibilidade da cucumina agora tô
traduzindo em inglês
e então a espirulina quando usado em
conjunto com cucumina aumenta a Bi
disponibilidade da cucumina em humanos e
animais
ã então é verdade que ele falou
tá
também a combinação do Black Comin né o
cinho preto com a
espirulina também pode ter esse efeito
de aumentar a biodisponibilidade da
cúrcuma
Então eu não sei se eu acho que não vai
dar não tá falando se é 30 vezes Tá mas
é uma boa isso daí eu não sabia tá vocês
me ensinaram uma coisa nova hoje aí eu
não sabia dessa história da espirulina
aumentar a absorção de cúrcuma
bacana gostei disso tá eu não tinha esse
conhecimento mas é verdade
[Música]
Renata ansiedade crônica extra csto
sintomática sem problema cardíaco
ansiedade
antecipatória adrenalina liberada por
qualquer motivo temho mê que meu coração
não consegue mais voltar à normalidade
exames físicos Ok tomo muito suplemento
mas nada tem ajudado sobre homeopatia
para esse caso posso manipular os
seguintes na potência
h30 então eu não sou homeopata Tá Renata
eu nem vou dar Pit porque eu não sou
homeopata tá o que eu faria no seu caso
o que o que eu poderia te sugerir de
homeopatia mas é homotoxicologia outra
linha isso aqui é pelo que eu tô vendo é
uma homeopatia Riana na aquela mais
convencional né
Eh eu sugeria você usar o an odoro o
ance odoro deixa eu
eh colocar
aqui esse ance odoro eu conheço já usei
várias vezes e é homeopatia tá só que é
um outro tipo de homeopatia tá Mas faça
meditação faça meditação faça meditação
faça meditação tá claro isso ah mas eu
não consigo não quero saber faça ah eu
não consigo faz um minuto por dia depois
aumenta faça a meditação Ok vamos
próximo Maria Helena fiz piridoxal e
melatonina mas esqueci de avisar e veio
cápsula com corante posso abrir para
tomar por causa da intolerância tamina
pode Mariana Geralmente se não tiver um
mecanismo aí de liberação lenta Você
pode abrir a cápsula tá só o gosto que
pode às vezes
irritar Lúcia por favor não estou
conseguindo encontrar o proenac que que
é
proenac
proenac será que você escreveu errado
não conheço Senac para mim aquele
negócio lá de de ó Senac São Paulo
cursos livres pro Senac eu não sei o que
que é isso não eu acho você escreveu
errado tá se você tiver ao vivo por
favor eh esclareça aí
tá que eu não
conheço Rita qual seria o nível ideel do
fibrinogênio se alto como baixar até 300
tá como baixar depende velita vai
depender mas geralmente com Nat kinas
picnogenol
tá
natoquinase penal 200 mg de cada um por
dia mas isso isso é geral tá E tem que
ver cada caso a caso qual seria um modo
eficiente prático sem grandes efeitos
colaterais de fazer uma
despara o jeito mais prático eu entendo
é você usar o bendazol que é baratíssimo
tem no posto de saúde toma bendazol 300
mg por dia três dias tá Quantas vezes ao
ano deve ser feita duas vezes agora tem
gente que prefere fazer o protocolo da
rud da clar que é bem mais complicado
né mas o mais simples seria usar o
bendazol
Maria Helena como tomar borax em
pó 100%
puro
eh eu não tenho prática com borax
tá vou checar para você
aqui vamos passar pro próximo Aí eu
volto nessa história do borax aqui daqui
a
pouco qual que é melhor progesteron
micronizado cápsulas ou transica Ah eu
geralmente eu tenho preferido usar em
cápsula porque é melhor o sono e tem um
efeito protetor
eh contra câncer de mama e endométrio
mais potente do que a transdérmica tá
então eu tenho usado nos últimos anos 1
ano do anos mais aoral do que a
transdérmica
Ok tenho preferido até que os estudos
que que eu vi falam mais da progesterona
vior
Eliane covial no pé é possível ter
relação com circulação não e
covial a causa não é circulação tá a
causa é trauma geralmente tá não é
circulação
[Música]
ã eu já vou voltar no borax tá vamos ver
as outras aqui Eliseu ao comer besteira
no shopping o dano causado é menor caso
a pessoa ten ingerido vinagre de maçã em
casa antes de pro shopping sim é menor
até falei isso num vídeo que eu tava
comentando lá o livro da doutora
bioquímica lá que eu tava fazendo react
eu acho que o pessoal não gostou do
react teve pouca visualização esse vídeo
aí
e mas eu falei nesse vídeo então e sim
vai Minimizar os danos sim a vinagre de
maçã Ok De que maneira vai diminuir a
absorção do açúcar essa que é a maneira
que isso vai ajudar beleza
na Live passada você deu a entender que
é melhor comprar alguns suplementos numa
farmácia de manipulação confiável
enquanto que outros é melhor comprar
importado no caso do omega3 não vale a
pena a farmá manipulação porque não
possui o selo ifos Meg não tem produto
de manipulação que tem Celo sim
tá não é tanto manipulação quanto não
manipulação tem bons
omega3 existe alum método caseiro para
saber se o bariátrico está absorvendo
bem os suplementos Que eu saiba não que
eu saiba não Eliseu
Ah tá mandando uma fórmula injetável
Qual é a sua opinião a respeito dessa
fórmula para
bariátricos sim tá tá repondo vários
minerais e vitaminas aí mas tem que ver
se a pessoa tá precisando mesmo né
dessa o trofan endovenoso pode dar muita
reação tá o muitas vezes é melhor fazer
intramuscular isso
aí não não tem como saber se as dosages
estão ideais o O Eliseu porque isso é
individual tá acrescentaria mais alguma
coisa dependendo dos exam sim não tem os
exames do paciente poderia acrescentar
mais itens sim
tá isso é uma coisa muito individual
muito particular não é um uma boa
pergunta pro grupo isso daí
não
Tiago qual seria a dose recomendada de L
glutationa fui comprar e tinha de 50 até
mg Eu geralmente eu passo GL sublingual
de 100 mg duas vezes ao dia então eu
daria uma dose aí em torno de 200 mg
máximo 500 um pouco alta mas um pass
muito intoxicada acho que até iria tá
tem que tomar só cuidado com a reação de
rheim né que se deslocar muito toxina
pode passar mal interfere com medicação
sim pode aumentar a metabolização de de
vários medicamentos pode acontecer isso
sim
e a r gluta reduzida teria uma absorção
melhor sim e a dose seria mesma da glut
normal não aí a dose seria uns 30% a
menos bem vamos voltar pro negócio aí da
questão do do
borax então borax é Borato sódio é um
composto químico usado para fins
industriais de limpeza Então não é
recomendado para uso
medicinal os riscos de ingerir e
irritação do trato gastrointestinal
danos aos zins alterações hormonais
toxicidade reprodutiva em dose muito
alta pode levar a convulsões como até
morte então me fale de onde é que saiu
essa história de usar borax para eu
entender melhor isso beleza
vamos a os comentários ao vivo aqui
deixa eu voltar
para aparecer
aqui quem é melhor para fornecer
cardápio para musculação nutricionista
ou esportiva ou integrativa esportiva né
que pra musculação vai ser melhor
esportiva quem é melhor para para
receitar cardápio não só respondi já
repetiu a pergunta
eh poderia falar um pouco sobre o p para
tratamento de dermatite
atópica tá Pe para dermatite
atópica já volto nessa nesse tema tá
o já volto nesse tema me dá só um um
instante aqui
eh eu não tenho muita prática com pe
para falar ver verdade mas eu vou
responder sua pergunta daqui a pouco eh
sobre o que o senhor comentou do
Hashimoto porque se deve retirar o leite
porque o leite tem a caseína que é uma
substância que emita o glúten e é que é
um frequente agressor da barreira
intestinal e que gera o problema do liqu
gante do intestino hiper permeável aí
passa proteínas não digeridas ou
peptídeos não digeridos pra corrente
sanguínea do da placa de p ali do
intestino delgado e o sistema imune
recebe essa informação esses Amino
produz anticorpos que vão atacar tireo
por causa
disso sobre despara tização deve ter
alguma relação com a necessidade de
comer doces depois que tomei extrato da
Dra ruda Clark nunca mais tive vontade
de comer tem tem a ver sim tem tanto
bactérias quanto parasitas que podem
aumentar a sua vontade de comer doce sim
tem a
ver dependendo da pessoa os receptores
de vitamina podem engolir tanto que
apenas com 2000 de vitamina D por dia a
pessoa pode chegar a 150
nanog olha com 2.000 por dia eu nunca vi
chegar nesse nesse ponto no sangue não
tá mas sim tem pessoas que tomando
10.000 pode chegar nesse valor
aí gastrite crônica moderada sem h pilor
tem me restringido muito uso de
suplementos alguma recomendação natural
usa espinheira santa guaçatonga e Zin
com carnosina e se você tiver o
intestino preso o Aloe Vera também tá
depois você volta no vídeo
eh assiste de novo para pegar tá bom
gente lembra esses vídeos todos ficam
gravados tá nenhum desses vídeos sai do
YouTube então tá ao vivo agora mas
depois fica a versão
gravada o bariátrico não consegue mais
absorver os suplementos não consegue sim
vai diminuir mas
consegue não aí você tá confundindo
suplemento com nutriente né o bariátrico
vai ter dificuldade de absorver
nutrientes e suplementos os dois né
agora B12 por exemplo bariátrico tem que
ser feito Eng gávio porque o não
consegue mais absorver vi oral tá ou
sublingual é necessário tomar nutrientes
pro resto da vida em muitos casos sim
Eliseu tem que tomar o resto da vida de
nada
Nilsa estou tendo um grande desafio com
a dermatite mesmo fazendo no protocolo
coíba Então vamos voltar nesse tema aí
do do
peia vamos voltar esse assunto do pé
aqui
então ô
Eliseu baratro costuma engordar tudo de
novo a partir de 6 anos de cirurgia isso
vai Metade dos bariátricos tem esse
problema depois de 6 anos de cirurgia
engorda tudo de novo talvez um pouco
mais 60% tem esse
problema
depende Eliseu tem gente que a saúde
fica pior e outros nem tanto se fizer a
reposição correta dos nutrientes que tá
em
falta então é porque o paciente que faz
a Bari ele fica o estômago desse tamanho
entendeu Então ele nem consegue comer
muita comida
mais ele é meio forçado a comer
pouco saudável boa parte deles não faz
diet saudável el simplesmente não
consegue comer muita quantidade come
comida ruim em pequena quantidade ele
não é obrigado a fazer dieta saudável
apesar de ser muito recomendado que faça
então vamos voltar pra história do pea
tá então o pea que é a palmito etanamida
que é um tipo aí de plasmalógenos né
Pode ser sim um tratamento promissor
paraa dermatite atópica né E tem ação
antiu alivia rapidamente a coceira e
redu a necessidade de coçar a pele
um estudo de 2015 avaliou a eficácia da
peia para dermatite atópica moderada e
encontrou uma redução de prurido do da
da coceira das lesões de pele melhor na
qualidade de vida ela parece eficaz e
segura para reduzir o prurido as lesões
de pele melhorando a qualidade de vida
né de cães estudo que foi feito em cães
com dermatite atópica moderada um estudo
2014 encontrou níveis aumentados de p na
pele com dermatite atópica em coração
com Pele Saudável sugerindo que o peia
pode fazer parte do mecanismo para o
corpo naturalmente manter a homeostase
da
pele
e então você acho uma boa você usar P
assim para dermatite atópica viu eu não
sabia disso também tô aprendendo isso
[Música]
agora Então aprendi hoje que o peia pode
ser bom para dematite atópica e
aprendi que a espirulina pode aumentar a
biodisponibilidade da cúrcuma legal isso
aqui gostei dessa Live de
hoje supondo que Auto emo seja eficaz
para aumento da imunidade alguém que
Possivelmente tenha tido o seu sistema
imune prejudicado por algum produto
também poderia fazer
uso sim poderia fazer uso sim
que produto você tá falando por algum
produto sim mas é eu gosto muito mais da
autoo com ozônio acho que faz mais
sentido mas sim poderia
fazer
Olha eu não sei como é que tá sendo
conduzido o Romário tá ele pode tá sendo
bem
conduzido se ele tiver sendo bem
conduzido ele vai ter qualidade de vida
só que vai ficar dependendo de
reposições que antes ele não precisava
[Música]
né a reposição monal prolongada por
muitos anos pode ser perigosa sim se for
feita do jeito errado pode
ser nos Estados Unidos falam isso não
estou entendendo porquê é porque tem
gente que exagera nas doses né Denise e
não usa os hormônios igual do organismos
bioidênticos isom moleculares né então
dose errada de uma coisa boa pode ser
ruim
né
eh não eu não conheço nada na medicina
natural que possa curar a genética de um
psicopata
tá produto
experimental
Ah tá você tá dizendo da né da
tá
é não vejo nenhum problema de fazer alto
emo para essa situação aqui não
tá suplemento na que elimina as toxinas
da castan de Caju crua não não faria
isso como por você tá cismado com castan
de Caju crua Ô Eliseu Não entendi tá
cismado com
isso é verdade que alimentação suação
para voltar o cabelo branco a sua cor
original até funciona mas é extremamente
demorado Demora sim eu demora eu não me
interessei nisso não Sinceramente eu não
tenho não me incomoda em nada meu cabelo
branco mas existe sim alguns pacientes
que me queixam disso passo ó
experimentação granola tem excesso de
óleo
vegetal excesso de óleo
vegetal por que excesso de óleo vegetal
Eliseu granola problema da granola que
geralmente ela tem muito carboidrato né
granola comum e tem o glúten Esse é o
problema da granola
comum quanto maior a massa muscular
menor o risco de pegar hipertensão não
tem muito fisiculturista que faz abuso
de esteroides que a pressão aumenta tudo
tem equilibro na vida não não não Lógico
o problema deles não é a massa muscular
em si mas é os efeitos colaterais dos
esteroides
né olha ele diz eu pode até destruir
alguns nutrientes mas eh tira a toxina
também
né Então vale a pena torrar o a ca de
cajor países que população não recebe
nada de sol como são altas as taxas de
autismo Isso é uma observação né Eh Ou é
uma pergunta acho que é uma
observação
eh Já estamos com 50 minutos de Live Eu
acho que já vou encerrar por aqui Alguém
tem mais alguma
pergunta não o açúcar não faz o magnésio
sai pela urina não o açúcar ele aumenta
o consumo de vitaminas do complexo B e
também pode aumentar o consumo de
magnésio mas não faz eliminar na urina
não você faz sentido comer ovos e carne
faz por não você pode comer mais de uma
fonte de proteína numa numa refeição não
tem
nenhuma demérito nisso nenhum problema
nisso
não três dias em jejum aumenta a
testosterona mais do que um dia em jejum
não sei el eu não conheço estudo
comparando isso não do autismo foi
pergunta Doutor foi uma pergunta pera aí
deixa eu voltar aqui você tá perguntando
se países que a população que não recebe
quase nada de sol
se as taxas de autismo são maiores não
sei dizer tem que tem que procurar Esse
estudo aí para te responder melhor mas
acho que sim faz sentido Tá mas eu teria
que perguntar isso
aí uma banana tem carboidrato suficiente
para potencializar o efeito da
creatina sim tem tem carboidrato
suficiente tem 20 G em média babosa po
tomado por mais de 10
dias pode
ah P de eletrólitos se tiver diarreia
sim se não tiver diarreia não tem perda
de eletrólitos não tá obrigado Adriana
pelo comentário também uma boa noite
descanso para
você e para sua família tudo de
bom
pessoal vamos fazer aqui uma rápida
enquete aqui quem gostou dos artigos que
eu troue hoje para vocês coloca o número
um tá Quem não gostou coloca o número
dois tá vai ser bem rápido aí a resposta
tá de novo quem gostou dos artigos
coloca número um Quem não gostou coloca
dois não tem problema de ser sincero
pessoal sou crescido suficiente para
aguentar frustração tá
Obrigado aí pelas respostas que já
vieram continuem respondendo tá um ou
dois quando a mamãe consome pouco ou
nenhum ômega-3 durante a reação o feto
puxa o pouco ômega-3 sim exatamente que
a mãe tem isso deixa lá deficiente
eh e por isso a mãe AP a falha de
memória não é necessariamente vai ter
falha de memória mas pode acontecer sim
tá todo mundo respondendo um se para me
agradar
mas bacana agradeço vocês aí eu quero
que a gente tenha aí
uma um ganho máximo possível que vocês
possam ter E se a gente tiver que fazer
algum ajuste nesse modelo a gente faz
OK tá eh
lembrar o pessoal do grupo aí eu peço a
ajuda de vocês tá que estão aqui ao vivo
comigo vão lá no grupo e lembrem as
pessoas de assistir os vídeos gravados
tá se perdeu a Live ao vivo pode
assistir depois gravado tá pessoal boa
noite obrigado pela audiência de
vocês pelas perguntas um beijo no
coração e até a próxima
semana